lo sapete ragazzi benvenuti a che cosa
ho detto jeff signori finalmente erano
poi non posso che essere una settimana
quindi sono un po scarico ma
ricarichiamo le pile
ma perché ho subito con la
consapevolezza di essere i migliori
perché con questo noi sappiamo di poter
fare la differenza non è milano ma la
carraia catani thani
non ho idea di dove sia questo posto
però vabbè droga nazionale brand masi
arca trend non si capisce un cazzo
indonesia è andata completamente di culo
lo sapeva dare un'idea di giura che ha
fatto a caso ho fatto totalmente a casa
perché ho detto vabbè si è più o meno
quella roba lì donesi thailandia pub
perfetto è andata a vera che ha battuto
hanno illuminato anche in tante persone
in sei abbiamo indovinato che tantissimo
considerando sta roba
c è solo dato completamente a caso cioè
vedendo un film e non è rispettato gli
altri bene la prima andata bene ragazzi
senza neanche googlare tra l'altro
fantastico noi siamo salvi già maps è
l'ex posizione francia le false le fans
del belgio le belgio o la frase fa o
francese o il belgio il pranzo arriva
bene jean jacques insurance questo lo
devo cercare ragazzi devo cercare jana
shakti maestri lanka sri lanka e meno
male raga del dato la bandiera e uscirà
anche è bellissimo è stata combattuta ma
ce l'ho fatta attenzione
ne mancano tre genoa 4 4 6 4 ma la somma
che c'è di male la gara la prima è
niente male
l'allenamento è stato buono ok però non
mi sembra giappone
poi magari mi sbaglio giappone vediamo
non era giappone era sud corea singapore
abbiamo bloccato tutti scusa tutti
l'abbiamo locata no perché loro casa per
ultimo ma va no già lo sapevo pure ci ha
scritto singapore
no non ci credo ma hanno bloccato fuori
urlo canova beh non era mai successo
ho lottato la risposta quindi quel è
rarissimo che riesce a indovinare
toccando la risposta è rarissimo
bloccate ho perso perché loro cara per
ultimo c'è pazzesca 9 pazzesca come
l'hai successo a cacchio che rosica
questo posto non è un'idea c'è un indica
deichmann mezza strada non c'è
un'indicazione non c è un indica serve
in mezzo dove cacchio siamo c'è una
bandiera che parlerà e non lo so non lo
so regala bandiera data da cieco eccola
no però siamo qua è se trova maniero
vinto ecco e miami la chiave ok era
veramente facile non le so le bandiere
rega non le so a questo è chiaramente
alice nel paese delle meraviglie alice
nel paese per forza che deve essere
marchi roma l'acqua siamo veramente casa
the eye di che cos'è
non c'è un indica cosa diavolo voi che
trovi qua non sanno manco loro tesoro ma
dove cacchio ma che ne so ragazzi no
questo è un paese scandinavo fidatevi è
un paese scandinavo tipo finland visto
azzeccato in pieno non c'è c'è un
cartello grazie perfetto adesso sì che è
chiaro
raga non ho idea di dove possa pezze
aspettata che secondo deve essere allora
la guida dove la guida la guida la guida
guida guida a destra qui la destra
inghilterra inghilterra inghilterra
guida a destra qui da destra guida a
destra guida a destra subito rally terra
blu ray o quinto calre irlanda in
irlanda si guida a destra chi guida a
destra in irlanda si guida a destra
proprio a loro ho beccato subito levy
importante guardare dove guida la gente
per capire se si è
in gran bretagna o no per adesso tutto
onesto andiamo per il prossimo che è
sicuramente italia non è vita già dalle
piante lo vedono già le piante non è
l'italia a tyla ero qua guarda non so
come si chiama ma so che qua so dov'è ma
nasce allora forse la thailandia ma non
ne sono vede no perché l'hanno già usata
quindi niente equa rega cambogia tipo
peccato ci ho provato ci devo provare la
beta o national gas
credo che sia cambiando brasile grazie
ad affermare il buon favi la trova
subito notata subito e sull'america
ragazzi che che è un casino
vediamo per la prima russia sul ma
guardo vista neanche la pista va da pam
blocco grazie qua istanti provvista qua
c'è la bandiera che sventola impartendo
bene anche un fazzoletto lega corre cosa
come la serbia può perché ho letto aerei
serbia che culo fa scuola in serbia ci
sta a bagnare la russia ma con adobe ha
come buono veramente capitale parcheggio
qua mi sa di qua potrebbe essere russia
o no non è vero è la madre stati uniti
ea bordo non ho visto non ho visto
niente che mi ricordava lista poco buone
0 però vabbè non è andata male che sono
tutti fortissimi cali al suo gioco sono
dei fenomeni c'è già interamente che
fornisce questo un cartello prima cosa
che guardo coin e inghilterra perché
come stanno in irlanda forteza forte
stai ogni in olanda in inghilterra new
york
rinuncio solo pinuccio lo indovina
proprio lui sarei dovuta andare a cui è
che quando ero quando andavo a scuola
perché
facevano gli scambi saranno tra studenti
che uno studente veniva in italia e tu
andavi bene la patria di poi facevate lo
scambio si chiama scambio si doveva
andare a cui poi non sono andate a cork
però sappiamo che come sta inghilterra
ancora c'è la signora che si è
affacciata la signora salve salve
signora che vede la macchina che fa le
foto albero dove cacchio siamo sì
collocato voi a casa sua questa è casa
sua ha lottato lui lui loca come cosa
dove quando come fai a locare brown
league è secco no a casa sua come
facevano carlo dopo la pole andare
storia figurati ma chi ma quando
ragazzine se la geox spero vi sia
piaciuto questo divieto molto e molto
difficile ma mi dà un sacco di
soddisfazioni quando azzecco quindi
vabbè però che gli sia piaciuto ragazzi
lo stesso divertire i formatori piace
anche questa descrizione dello stato i
siti schede ci vediamo come sempre ad un
prossimo vito è da ragazzi
[Musica]